Physiologically, marijuana increases heart rate, bronchodilation, reddening of
the eyes, and dryness of the throat and mouth. In addition, there's some
perceptual changes such as difficulty estimating time, sometimes referred to as
time expansion, verbal behavior decreases. Whereas there's an increase in
nonverbal behaviors or interactions. Sometimes people report feeling giddy, but
sometimes people also experience anxiety and its these users who report feeling
like will not return back to normal. Acute administration of marijuana can
disrupt cognitive performance including slowed cognitive processing, impaired
short term memory. Impaired inhibitory control. Loss of sustained
concentration. And impaired visuospatial processing. Medically, marijuana has
been shown to be beneficial for some chronic pain, nausea, and anxiety.
However, medical acceptance of marijuana is still under debate. Now, let's go
back to Susan for the last class of drugs we're going to be covering in this
lesson.